Estonia. 1991.
Tras más de 50 años de ocupación soviética
y dictadura comunista, Estonia recuperaba
su independencia. El legado de la época comunista
para los estonios fue, al igual que para todos
los países restantes de la extinta Unión
Soviética, nefasto.
En 1991, el PIB per cápita estonio no llegaba
a los 3.500 dólares, el equivalente hoy a
países como Bolivia o El Salvador.
Claro que lo peor aún estaba por llegar.
La desintegración del bloque soviético supuso
un duro mazazo para sus países miembros.
Y por supuesto Estonia no fue una excepción.
En 1992 su economía se contrajo más de un
20%.
Era la hora de construir un nuevo modelo de
país.
Y queridos amigos, amigas, esta fue una idea
que los estonios se tomaron muy pero que muy
en serio.
Mientras que algunos de los nuevos países
herederos de la Unión Soviética, como Ucrania,
Uzbekistán y Bielorrusia se hundieron en
la inestabilidad, la crisis y la autocracia,
la historia de Estonia fue completamente diferente.
(Estonia es hoy uno de los países más prósperos
de todo el mundo. Su potencial es inmenso
y su nivel de vida no deja de mejorar. En
2020 el PIB per cápita ajustado por la diferencia
de precios de Estonia se aproximó a los 40.000
dólares, algo que le ha permitido ya superar
a países como España.)
Y eso no es todo. La evolución de prácticamente
todos sus parámetros macroeconómicos vence
de largo no solo a España sino a la mayoría
de países de la Unión Europea.
Por ejemplo, es uno de los países con las
cuentas públicas más saneadas de todo el
mundo y es el país de Europa con mayores
tasas de emprendimiento en relación a su
población. Cada año se crean más de 20
empresas por cada 1.000 habitantes, 6 veces
más que la media comunitaria.
Queridos amigos, amigas, Estonia se ha convertido
en el país de los emprendedores europeos.
Algo así como un pequeño, y eso sí, gélido
Silicon Valley en plena Unión Europea.
Pero dicho esto la pregunta es, ¿Cómo demonios
han logrado semejante evolución en tan poco
tiempo? ¿Qué esconde el modelo estonio?
¿Cuáles son los ingredientes de su éxito?
Pues… Aquí, tal y como ya os comentamos
en un vídeo especial en Patreon, podemos
destacar varios factores: desde la política
fiscal hasta su apuesta por la tecnología.
Y, también, entre los ingredientes más importantes
del éxito estonio se encuentra su sistema
educativo.
Puede que no lo sepas y que nunca te lo hubieras
imaginado pero Estonia tiene el mejor sistema
educativo de toda Europa. De hecho se califica
así misma como la “Education Nation”,
la nación de la educación.
Pero, ¿Queréis saber qué tiene de especial
su sistema educativo? ¿Cuáles son exactamente
sus características y claves más importantes?
Pues… Atentos.
(MÁS IMPORTANTE EL ‘CÓMO’ QUE EL ‘CUÁNTO’)
El éxito del modelo educativo estonio no
es una opinión, es algo acreditado por todas
las instituciones dedicadas a evaluar los
diferentes sistemas educativos, incluido por
supuesto el informe PISA.
En PISA, Estonia está literalmente no solo
a la cabeza de Europa sino de todo el mundo.
Tras Singapur, este pequeño país báltico
es el país que mejor calificación obtiene
en las tres competencias básicas: lectura,
matemáticas y ciencia.
(Y no solo esto. Estonia también tiene el
mayor porcentaje del mundo de estudiantes
con alto rendimiento académico que provienen
de familias pobres. Y la menor diferencia
en resultados entre el entorno rural y el
entorno urbano. La menor tasa de estudiantes
sin educación básica - apenas un 5% - y
una de las tasas de repetición de curso más
bajas de toda la OCDE.
Apenas el 3,5% de los estudiantes de hasta
15 años repiten alguna vez, frente a la media
del 12,4%. Por si fuera poco también se coloca
a la cabeza en cuanto a dominio de lenguas
extranjeras)
Amigos, aquí el ascensor social funciona
a toda velocidad. Y para que nos entendamos,
podemos decir que Estonia ha adelantado por
la derecha al sistema educativo de la mismísima
Finlandia, el hasta ahora referente de toda
Europa en materia educativa.
Ahora bien, ¿Cómo lo han conseguido? Y justo
aquí sé lo que muchos estáis pensando:
Alberto, seguro, seguro que se gastan una
barbaridad en educación.
Pues… No, estáis muy pero que muy equivocados.
Sí, Estonia hace un importante esfuerzo en
educación, pero el gasto público por alumno
no es ni de lejos el más alto de la OCDE.
Ni siquiera si ajustamos el gasto por la diferencia
de precios y salarios.
De hecho, hay muchos países con un gasto
por alumno muy superior y que sin embargo
obtienen resultados mucho peores.
¿Queréis un ejemplo? Pues sin ir más lejos…
España. Fijaos.
Ya lo véis, a pesar de cosechar holgadamente
los mejores resultados educativos, Estonia
no es ni de lejos el país que más gasta
en educación por alumno. De hecho, su nivel
de gasto se sitúa bastante por debajo de
la media de la OCDE y de la Unión Europea
incluso si tenemos en cuenta la diferencia
de precios.
Lo cual nos lleva directamente a una idea
que creo conviene repetir:
[NO. Señores políticos, gastar más en educación
NO es la receta simple del éxito. Si fuera
tan sencillo, sería, no sé, muy fácil,
¿no os parece? Bastaría con gastar más
y más para obtener mejores resultados.
Pero… La realidad, sin embargo, es totalmente
diferente. Esto no va de cuánto se gaste
sino sobre todo de cómo. Así que, por favor,
políticos y periodistas de todos los colores
y partidos, dejad de una vez por todas de
utilizar el mantra del dinero.]
Pongamos un ejemplo. Islandia gasta por alumno
mucho, muchísimo más que Estonia incluso,
repito, teniendo en cuenta la diferencia de
salarios y precios.
Así que si nos guiamos por la lógica política
de que a más gasto mejores resultados, entonces
Islandia tendría que tener un sistema educativo
mucho mejor que Estonia. Sin embargo, ¡Sorpresa!
No es que Estonia gane, es que Islandia, por
ejemplo en PISA, es uno de los peores países
de Europa-
El gasto, amigos, no lo es todo. Pero dicho
esto y ahora que ya sabemos que no es simplemente
una cuestión de pasta, ¿Qué os parece si
nos ponemos el buzo de trabajo y nos sumergimos
de lleno en las claves del sistema educativo
de Estonia?
¿Qué podemos aprender de él?
Atentos.
(LOS PILARES DE LA PROSPERIDAD ESTONIA))
Querida comunidad de VisualPolitik, resetead
vuestra mente durante un buen rato porque
el modelo educativo del que os vamos a hablar
seguro, seguro que tiene poco que ver con
lo que hayáis visto hasta ahora.
Vamos a hablar de un modelo educativo que
extrañamente no está subordinado a intereses
políticos, sino a las necesidades de capital
humano que tiene el mundo moderno, incluyendo
por supuesto el mundo de la empresa y el emprendimiento.
[Espera, espera, un momento… ¿Un sistema
educativo diseñado para que los estudiantes
puedan encontrar un trabajo de alta cualificación
rápidamente al terminar sus estudios? De
locos]
Pues, sí, no nos hemos equivocado. En Estonia
la educación se ha situado como uno de los
ejes clave sobre los que pivotan los planes
económicos del país.
Ahora bien, ¿en qué se diferencia, exactamente,
el modelo educativo estonio del de otros países?
Pues veréis, la primera clave la podemos
encontrar en la independencia. Independencia
tanto de escuelas como de profesores.
(Aunque en Estonia todas los centros educativos
tienen que ceñirse a un programa marco de
contenidos mínimos fijado por el gobierno,
la aplicación de este marco es muy abierta,
y cada colegio, instituto o, incluso, cada
profesor, tiene mucha independencia para decidir
tanto el currículo educativo final como el
método.)
Y creedme si os digo que tanto centros como
profesores son los primeros interesados en
que todo esto funcione.
Entre otras cosas por el modelo estonio dual
de financiación pública de la educación.
[Espera, espera, ¿modelo qué? ¿Qué diantres
es eso?]
Pues, veréis. En Estonia la educación privada
es testimonial, residual. Sin embargo, lo
cierto es que los centros educativos públicos
están sometidos a un intenso modelo de competencia.
(Por un lado la financiación de los centros
sigue una filosofía que se parece bastante
al proceso de competencia de mercado. El ingreso
que las escuelas reciben está determinado
por el número de alumnos que consigan. Cuántos
más alumnos logre un centro mayor será su
financiación.
Por otro lado, el rendimiento académico y
las características de cada centro se evalúan
constantemente y los resultados son totalmente
públicos. Esto genera la dinámica competitiva
de que los padres quieran inscribir a sus
hijos en los mejores colegios e institutos,
los cuales al lograr más alumnos consiguen
más financiación.
Este proceso, además, incrementa la presión
sobre los responsables y profesores de los
centros con peor rendimiento haciendo que
se tengan que poner las pilas .)
Y no solo eso. Ya no se trata solo de que
los mejores colegios e institutos logren más
demanda, más reputación y más recursos.
Sino que además los buenos resultados garantizan
también su supervivencia.
Porque… Amigos, uno de los grandes retos
a los que se enfrenta Estonia es la demografía.
En los últimos 15 años el número de estudiantes
en el país ha caído un 40%, lo que ha obligado
al Gobierno y a los municipios a ir cerrando
los colegios e institutos que sobran. Eso
sí, se cierran los que peores resultados
obtienen.
Así que ya os podéis imaginar el interés
que tanto las escuelas como los profesores
tienen para mejorar sus resultados y atraer
más alumnos.
Por cierto, que en este punto hay que decir
que los directores y los órganos de dirección
de cada centro cuentan con un nivel de autonomía
muy alto para cosas como, por ejemplo, decidir
a qué profesores contratan, que salarios
reciben o como reparten los fondos que reciben
del gobierno.
Sí, sí, lo habéis escuchado bien: Los salarios
de los profesores en Estonia no son los mismos
en todas las escuelas ni se determinan mediante
convenio colectivo. Se deciden en los propios
centros.
Por supuesto cuánto más fondos reciba un
centro mayores salarios podrá pagar. Es simple
y llanamente el resultado de la competencia.
Además, esta enorme autonomía permite que
cada centro pueda diferenciarse de otros especializándose
en diferentes cuestiones: arte, economía,
ciencias, etcétera, etcétera.
Incluso existen las llamadas “escuelas de
élite”, un tipo de centro pensado para
poder desarrollar todas las capacidades de
los alumnos más brillantes.
Pero no aquí termina todo.
Los profesores también están supeditados
a mayores niveles de competencia y más responsabilidades
que en otros países.
M(En Estonia si los alumnos tienen malos resultados
de forma prolongada el profesor puede ser
despedido. Pero para no tener que llegar a
ese extremo, en este país los profesores
reciben una intensa formación continua, lo
que les permite mejorar y reciclarse en cuanto
a conocimientos, contenidos o métodos de
enseñanza. Es una formación intensa y obligatoria
que conlleva muchos beneficios: por ejemplo
la adaptación a las nuevas tecnologías.)
A cambio los profesores, cuentan con más
libertad docente e influencia en la toma de
decisiones.
¿No os parece sorprendente? Todo, absolutamente
todo el modelo educativo de Estonia se basa
en la competencia. Y recordad que hablamos
de un sistema esencialmente público. Parece
casi de otro mundo.
Ahora bien, llegados a este punto es posible
que os estéis preguntando: Vale, vale, pero,
¿Cómo es exactamente el curriculum escolar?
¿Tiene algo que ver con la altísima tasa
de creación de empresas que tiene el país?
Atentos.
(CODO CON CODO HASTA EL ÉXITO FINAL)
Lo mencionamos ya al principio del vídeo:
el modelo educativo de Estonia está orientado,
sobre todo, a la empresa y a la preparación
para el mundo laboral.
Por ejemplo, en el diseño de los programas
académicos participan tanto representantes
de la sociedad civil como de las propias empresas.
Pero esa no es la única vía de colaboración.
Tanto la educación secundaria como la educación
terciaria cuentan con amplios programas de
prácticas laborales que permiten que los
estudiantes estonios accedan al mercado laboral
con algo de experiencia.
En este sentido, Estonia ha apostado muy fuerte
por incluir las prácticas de trabajo en la
educación vocacional, que sería el equivalente
a la formación profesional, y también en
los másteres universitarios.
Y ojo que no hablamos del típico mes de prácticas.
Estos programas contemplan que las prácticas
laborales supongan hasta el 50% de las horas
de formación.
Pero al margen de la colaboración con empresas,
podemos destacar otra característica muy
particular: los estonios están obsesionados
con la igualdad en la etapa educativa.
Y no estoy hablando de una igualdad entendida
como hacer que todos consigan el título,
sino que todos tengan las mismas condiciones
sea cual sea su entorno socioeconómico. Es
decir, igualdad de oportunidades, no de resultados.
(Esto supone que en Estonia no solo la educación
está pagada por el Estado, incluida la Universidad,
sino también los libros de textos e, incluso,
el comedor. Los estudiantes de educación
obligatoria tienen comida gratis en la escuela.
Además, todos los alumnos hasta los 19 años
tienen una cobertura sanitaria gratuita, así
como enfermeras en los colegios de primaria,
chequeos médicos rutinarios gratuitos y dentista
gratis.)
La idea fundamental es que sea cual sea su
nivel socioeconómico todos los estudiantes
puedan tener las mismas oportunidades.
En fin, competencia, especialización, integración
con la empresa e igualdad de oportunidades
en un país con poca burocracia y bajos impuestos.
No está nada mal, ¿No os parece?
Por supuesto, no todo es perfecto. Y aunque
el sistema educativo de Estonia ha demostrado
ser hoy por hoy el mejor de toda Europa con
mucha diferencia, todavía tiene algún que
otro reto. Sobre todo dos: la escasez de profesores
de materias específicas y la mejora en el
rendimiento educativo de los estudiantes de
etnia rusa.
Queridos amigos, amigas, estas son las claves
del modelo educativo de Estonia, el mejor
sistema educativo de toda Europa y uno de
los mejores del mundo. Uno de los ingredientes
que ha permitido que este país no solo de
un enorme salto en prosperidad sino que se
convierta también en un líder tecnológico
y en todo un semillero de Start-ups.
La pregunta es: ¿Creéis que vuestro país
debería tomar nota del éxito estonio? ¿Qué
os gustaría ver en vuestros países?
Dejadnos vuestros comentarios aquí debajo,
y como siempre, si te ha gustado este vídeo
dale a like y suscríbete a nuestro canal
haciendo clic en la campanita.
¡Y por cierto! Si te gusta el trabajo que
hacemos, apóyanos y únete a nuestra comunidad
en Patreon, donde además de contribuir con
Visual Politik obtendrás contenidos exclusivos,
así como regalos periódicos y mucho más.
Os dejamos el enlace en la descripción.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.